well we can look among many different
new models but if we want a new modern
life for responding to the complexity of
the world probably the best modern the
best new model could be try to simplify
the complexity which means look to all
the massive regulation which does exist
today at international and domestic
level look what is working what does not
work the lead what doesn't work make
effective what works what could work
much better and simplify the life of the
people because the people will
understand which regulation is
regulating home my metaphor is very
simple we are living today in the
forestry where you have a lot of trees
cut those trees which are almost dead
and you will see that you stay with few
trees and you will see the lights of the
Sun and these will left people to be
much better simplify and force what you
have reduce the complexity